what I'm that to show you kinda really
goes with 12c oh but this feels like an
original submission it and it's a great
new result it's kind of strange and
flows out from what we're doing in 0 do
you remember having look at a particular
graph I was doing it again with you and
I think it was this mystery do you
member this one surely get it hasn't
been that long right now the particular
thing that I was started thinking about
was in part c they ask us about tell me
the behavior of why as x approaches
infinity and you remember that as we go
all the way up to the right-hand side of
the axis of the plane what is why doing
right and I conclusion we can see what
is that the limit as X approaches
infinity of y equals zero that's a
conclusion we can soon we kind of did a
bit of a well to be honest it was a bit
of a fudge it was nothing rigorous it's
just kind of well you know this is
polynomial this is exponential
exponential connor winds like
categorically just winds right now i did
not i didn't approve that in any way i
just kind of showed you a few clues that
point in that direction and it is true
now i want to show you a similar kind of
problem now which relates to what we
what we now know about logarithmic
functions and how to integrate and
result in those and this am I going to
do a rigorously okay now before I show
you the answer what does your intuition
tell you as X approaches infinity you've
got a thing that's well they're both
guys they're both growing this week's X
is growing slower than this right
because this guy is just marching long
at a linear rate never speeds up and
slows down whereas the log curve is
doing what they're slowing down its
concave down on even though it's always
increasing rates of its do enough you've
seen the shape or form so therefore your
intuition pro tells me even though
they're both growing we tried is growing
faster the denominator right so the
denominator is going faster and the
whole thing probably tends toward zero
right because if the denominator is
being bigger the hole
getting smaller okay so 0 that's our
intuition tells us I am going to use
integration to show you that that is to
do ok so we're going to prove it do a
realistic okay now to help us what I
like to do is help me grab something
we're going to grab just one half of the
hyperbola water friends okay so we only
need it in the first quadrant
um you know what obviously entirely know
what to call this what are you what do
you want I don't want to title you don't
deserve the title but that could
actually make sure if it's like people
get items like Lady good start anyway
I'm sure by the end of this will be able
to decide on a time scale I have my book
pepper okay now this is this is what
would the equation of a standard I
probably what were you yeah we would
usually call wipers 10 stand that's how
i've labeled my axes however i'm just a
little bit unusual and i hope you will
see why i don't know maybe in a few
minutes i'm actually not going to make
this the XY axis i'm going to do
something important with X later on it's
going to come into my proof in an
important way later so therefore since
i'm going to use X a bit later on I'm
going to use a different variable I'm
just going to give a different thing if
you remember when we're looking
integration if I do something like say
yes right because if I've got my actual
boundaries that X is just going to
disappear some numbers are just going to
go in there and replace the X the X just
kind of stands in that's why we call it
do you member what it's calling dummy
variable okay so this is really the same
as now I can use any I can pick any
credible alike really ok I'm just going
to use T than that because teasing
rabbit it's a parameter penalty so make
this the T axis so you are saying to you
before all this if you like like as one
of Rex since I've got T axis
i'm going to call this y equals want to
move up now i'm interested in a
particular area under this graph okay
namely the area from T equals 1 this is
the bit of a weird part up until it is
this expertise mentioning I want to go
all the way to root X where X is some
value of x variable I'm going to use
that later on okay so extra be 10 185
whatever you like this is the area how
interested in so long as X is greater
than one it's going to be somewhere
everything to the right of 117 know so T
is access right and X is another
variable I'm introduce you in fact it's
going to be part of this part of the
balance right I cover this up x into
itself but i'm going to use t as my
standing variable and X will appear
winner substitute alright so let's just
check our earlier ok now this area
that's a nice simple area there's
nothing happening in terms of like no
positive the hairs there's no bits that
are all like sliced up and any disbanded
in that boundary some of the strangers
you've been dealing with like that are
hard to deal with but this is a very
simple area to evaluate right what
integral would I fall
that are that's the area that's the
green area so that integral corresponds
to this area let's next I'm going to do
it seems completely uninjured it's like
why would you bother doing them but
you'll see what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to get a value for this it's very
closely connected to this guy that I'm
trying to get the limit on okay do you
agree that the gray area it's an actual
area like it actually occupies space you
agree with that it's positive because
all about the axis okay so therefore I
should be able to say that that area is
greater than zero you agree with that I
know I've written it on the other side
which is a bit weird but that's because
i'm going to write something else on the
other side of the integral in the middle
this area is an actual area occupy space
and some of the actors so therefore this
area is great material for the same time
this area is smaller than like it's not
an infinite area I can put some
boundaries around this and say well
whatever the area is it's going to be
less than and I can put some different
boxes in here that will give me like an
actual boundary right at the actual
interesting soon low-speed some space
the actual box I'm going to pour on it
to make this as simple as I possibly can
he is with my glue go this box
ok have a look at that box with me it's
a strange box to pick out I'm picking it
for two reasons number one is clearly
bigger than my green area think everyone
agrees it has to be bigger right no
matter where this green area goes off to
write the blue box is going to grow with
it right and the blue box will always be
larger does that make sense not only
that that's the first reason the second
thing is the blue box is very easy to
calculate the area all right all I need
is a height and width how high is it
it's one unit that's one because if this
is T equals 1 then 1 over T is 1 over 1
so i had that height the width of course
is relaxed because from 0 to read out so
I've got this distance of course yeah
yeah that's a good question why why
wouldn't I just put like this box in
here I could but because of the
dimensions that I've got now this thing
is simply to deal with like I've got a
less complicated with still the same
time ok so really I'm just I could do
exactly what I want to prove through
your mechanism but this will just be
simpler algebra really